you
over the course of the last two videos
we've looked at some of the most
terrifying weapons ever devised as
interesting as that is it's kind of
depressing so in this video we're going
to look at some of the least effective
weapons in all of history so without
further ado and in no particular order
to the list first up one of my favorites
the double-barreled cannon you've
probably never heard of this abomination
but the idea has been around for a very
long time the concept was the brainchild
of Italian gun maker Antonio Petrini way
back in 1642 the idea was simple fire to
cannonballs simultaneously these
cannonballs were linked by a chain which
worked like a massive bola snapping
trees and cycling through infantry at
least that's how it was intended
fast-forward to 1862 a mechanic from
Georgia named John Gilliland had managed
to raise the funds to build his own
double-barreled cannon the gun was cast
in one piece for structural integrity
and featured twin barrels that angled
just barely away from each other
intended to stretch the chain caught
between the projectiles then the testing
began the problem with double barreled
powder weapons is that it's nearly
impossible to get them to fire
simultaneously if one fires a fraction
of a second sooner than the other the
projectiles can launch way off course
and cause serious damage or in the
worst-case scenario one cannon can fail
to fire and send the remaining ball
swinging back around to the shooter with
these facts in mind what do you think
happened in Gilliland tests if you said
destroyed an innocent cornfield
obliterated unsuspecting trees and
killed a poor unlucky cow you're right
next on our list is an especially
misguided Soviet invention from World
War two the Russians were in need of a
more effective method to take out German
tanks so naturally they strapped
anti-tank mines to the backs of dogs
here's how it was supposed to work the
dogs would seek out German tanks crawl
under them and when the detonating rod
attached to their explosives hit the
bottom of the tank no more fight oh and
no more tank in practice it turned out
quite differently the Russians would
hide treats under their t-34 tanks to
train the dogs to crawl under and fetch
them easy enough except the t-34 said
noisy diesel engines and smelled
entirely different from the German tanks
which used gasoline powered engines so
let's put two and two together here you
train a dog to fetch treats under your
own tanks then you take them into a
noisy chaotic battlefield and set them
loose where to spot run right under your
own tanks
some dogs wouldn't know what to do and
would come running back to the Russian
defenses where they would bump something
with their detonating rod and play dead
number three on our list is the Russian
Tsar tank from World War one it would be
really cool if it weren't so
horrifyingly useless the design was
almost clever the designers understood
the tanks with caterpillar tracks often
got stuck in mud and craters so instead
they opted for giant wheels when I say
giant I mean these things were huge nine
meters in diameter they were intended to
help the Tsar tank cross significant
obstacles that would stop a traditional
tank unfortunately there were some
miscalculations with the weight
distribution which led to the smaller
rear wheel getting stuck in the mud this
beast would have housed a crew of 18 and
been armed with either cannons or
machine guns into turrets one on top of
the carriage and a smaller one slung
underneath additional machineguns could
be placed inside the sponsons the small
armored pods behind the wheels when the
single prototype was ready the
real-world tests began the trials went
well at first the tank crushed obstacles
like trees with ease but then its fatal
flaw was revealed when the tank reached
uneven terrain the sort that you'd see
on the battlefield the back wheel became
hopelessly stuck the Tsar tanks massive
60 tonne weight was so unevenly
distributed that it couldn't even be dug
out so there at stade never seeing
action and slowly rusting away until it
was sold for scrap in 1923 as terribly
ineffective as the Tsar tank was it
captures the interest of many to this
day and there are rumours it's being
considered as a new piece of content for
battlefield 1 the last weapon on our
list might just take the cake it was
called the blue peacock nuclear mine and
it was developed by the British for use
in Germany in the 1950s the project's
goal was to bury ten of these ten
kiloton nuclear mines in the North
German plain in preparation for a Soviet
invasion from the east british officials
stated that they wanted to not only
destroy facilities and installations
over a large area but deny occupation of
the area to an enemy for an appreciable
time due to contamination the bombs were
to have three methods of detonation
first they could be triggered by wire
from three miles away second they could
be set on an eight-day timer or third
they would automatically detonate if
their anti-tamper devices were tripped
okay so they're big nuclear mines what's
the problem with that well aside from
how the Germans would have felt if ten
nukes blew up in their backyard it's how
the British solves the temperature
problem that earns this weapon as bottom
list the problem was that German winters
can get very cold especially for metal
objects buried in the dirt the British
were concerned that the sensitive
electronics inside the mines would fail
after a few days of extreme cold so they
devised a plan to keep them warm
throughout the winter the proposed
solution very live chickens with the
bombs that's right the plan was to bury
live birds along with feed and chicken
wire to keep them from pecking at the
bombs apparently their body temperature
alone would have been sufficient to keep
the electronics functioning properly
luckily for everyone the project was
scrapped in 1958 out of concern for the
nuclear fallout and political risks of
burying nuclear weapons in allied
territory of course there have been
plenty of other ineffective misguided
and just plain stupid weapons developed
throughout history I've just provided a
few to spark your interest if you
enjoyed this video please take a moment
to subscribe to my channel and keep
up-to-date with the latest content feel
free to leave a like or a dislike as you
please and tell me about your favourite
failed weapons in the comments you can
watch my previous video by clicking here
or binge watch them all by clicking here
thanks for watching and I'll see you in
the next video
you
[Music]